hi everyone my name is gary goldberg i'm
a phd student at weizmann institute of
science
and i'm going to talk today about a
joint work with guy gosling about
sample-based proofs of proximity
and before i present the model we
started in this work let's begin by
talking about a problem
say that i have two strings and i want
to check if they are identical
if i want to be absolutely a show in my
answer
i might
must read all of the bits of both of the
strings
but what if i only need to distinguish
between the case that the strings are
equal
and the case that they are far from java
that is that they need to change at
least an epsilon fraction
of the bits of the third string to get
to the second string
and let's also say that they need to
reject such bad inputs only with a high
probability say of two things
then in this case i have an algorithm
that reads much less than all of them
and this algorithm or when i test them
and it works as follows
choose uniformly random and index j from
1 to n
grid y j and z and check if they are
identical or not
if y equals then
we will always accept
but if y is fast from z
then with probability of epsilon
we would catch an index where y and z
disagree
and in this case we would reject
so by repeating this a simple test for
about one of the electron times
we get a tester that rejects with a high
probability
uh inputs that are foul
from being the same
and
so so we get a query based tester that
uh
[Music]
with a complexity of one version and
this square complexity does not depend
on m
and so it can be very small
and
in some sense we
really need that
to have the ability to perform queries
for this
algorithm we need to query y and z at
the same index
another
model of access which a tester might
have is simple based access
and in this
model
instead of being able to make queries
the tester gets samples of the input
each sample is of the form i which is
the index of the sample and the value of
the input at that location
and the samples are distributed
uniformly random and independent of each
other
and so now we cannot do what we did
before we cannot query a y interest at
the same place
uh
and
actually the best best thing we can do
is just draw samples at random
and wait until we are lucky and hit y
and z at the same index
and and for a birthday uh paradox
argument and you can see that it
requires at least square root of n
samples in order to hit such a collision
with the probability high enough
so we had one problem where with a
queerbase tester uh we could solve it
with very low query complexity
but with a sample based tester
we had to
draw a lot of circuits
can we so ha somehow help
the sample-based tester
and
decrease the number of samples it needs
to draw
one possibility is to give it the the
help of a product
so in interactive proximity
we allow the tester which we now call
verifier to communicate with a powerful
but untrusted proven
so the verifier might have query excess
of sample based access
and we assume that approval has all of
the input testing gigs
and we want
two things from such a
proof system
first is completeness we want that if x
is in the language we test
and then that there will be some
approval that will be able to convince
us and to accept the input
and on the other end we want soundness
we want that if x is far from being in
the language that is that it is far from
every word which is in the language
then
no prover no matter what it tells us
won't be able to
convince us to accept
except of a small probability of error
and again we are interested in the
number of queries or examples
that we take from the input
but in addition we are also interested
in the communication complexity of the
protocol which is the total number of
bits exchanged between the two parties
field in the protocol
we also want it to be a subliminal
because if we allow
linear communication complexity
well the approval can simply send us the
entire input
and the verifier can uh check that the
input it got from the provider
equals with high probability to the real
input
by drawing only
a few samples of the real input
and then it can check this and
that's it
and
another measure of complexity
is the number of forms and where in each
round each party can send a single
message to the other party
what we have now is actually four models
so in the
property testing area we have tester
without approval
and it might have query access or simple
access
to the input
recent line of study is about what can
we do with such interactive proof of
proximity
when the verifier has query access to
the input and we measure
the complexity of it
and the model we start to study in this
work is about the power of interactive
proximity
when the verifier is restricted to have
sample based access to the
input for
the quality of testing problem that we
saw
we have a single round uh sample based
interactive proximity
which is very efficient in terms of
sample and communication complexities we
are going to describe it
now
and it works as follows the verifier
starts by drawing a single sample let's
say it was in index i
and it is going to send to the cover
this index but modulu m
so if i is
less than n it's going to send i and if
i is larger than n it's going to send i
minus m
the completeness case
when y equals z
the prover is going to send a single bit
to the verifier which equals y is yj
which is the same as zj
the verify is going to get respect and
verify that it equals to the value
it got from example
in the soundness case
if y is epsilon far from zero
with a probability of epsilon
we are going to catch
a j
where yj is not equal to zj
and what
what can the prover do in this case
the point is that it doesn't know if we
sampled
the wipeout of the z-part thing
so
the best approval can do is to send us a
totally random bit sb
and now in this case
we catch the life approval with
probability half
so by repeating this a small protocol
for one of the epsilon times and we can
do it in parallel to maintain the one
round
and we get a sample-based interactive
systems with high soundness and full
completeness
and the sample complexity is very low
it's one over epsilon and the
communication complexity is also good
it's logarithmic because in each
such small step we only need to send
an index
and compare this to the
a
sample-based tester that didn't have a
power where the sample complexity was
much higher it was square root of n
this sample-based protocol in some sense
is kind of a simulation of the query
based tester for equality testing but
with help of approval
and in the paper we show that we can
generalize this protocol
and we show that if we have some
language that has a query based tester
with good
query complexity
it means that the same language has
a simple based interactive proof of
proximity
with good sample complexity and
communication complexity
but what happens if the language we have
doesn't have a query based tester can we
do something then
our main result
of the paper
is a reduction
we saw that if a language has a query
based interactive proximity
it also has a sample-based interactive
proof of proximity
and the overhead of the reduction is
pretty small if we start with a
query-based protocol with
a query complexity q and communication
complexity c
the sample-based protocol we get
is about
over the q
septo complexity and q plus c
communication complexity
and why this helps this helps us this
reduction
well
because we know of rich families of
languages
that all of them have
interactive proof systems with query x
to the input
so by applying
this reduction to those families
we get that all of the languages in
these families also has also have sample
based interactive proximity
which
in theory is supposed to be much more
limited than a query access
protocols
and by applying this reduction the first
result we get is that every language
which is computable by a low depth
circuit
has a simple based interactive proof of
proximity with about square root n
sample and communication complexity
and the second result is that every
language which is computable in
polynomial time and bounded polynomial
space also has sample based interactive
proximity
with again about square root of n sample
and communication complexities
and we note that also the round
complexity of both of the
results is reasonable
and both of the protocols are doubly
efficient so they're almost overruns in
time polynomial in the length of the
input
the verifier running time in both cases
is sublinear
and
so you can
use those
protocols
and before we show the
proof to the reduction or sketch to the
proof of the reduction and i want to
briefly
present two other results we have in
paper which are lower bounds
the first result is about the power of
non-interactive system
so in such a proof system and we limit
the power to send a single match message
to the verifier we call this message
approve
and now the verifier can read all of
this proof
and can also draw samples from the input
and again it's to accept objects input
and what we show in the paper is that
for equality testing if a proof system
is sub if the proof length is sub linear
then the sample complexity of the
verifier
must be
at least square root of n
and remember that
the the sample-based tester without the
total can already test equality with
square root of n symbols
so what this result means is that
there is no
non-trivial non-interactive proof system
for equality
the second result is about the power of
public coin interactive systems
in a public coin protocol
we restrict the messages of the verifier
to the proverb to be a random base so it
cannot send
any other messages
except for totally random bits to the
approval
and we show that in this case if the
sample complexity of the verifier is
below square root of n
then
the communication complexity times the
sample complexity
is at least
square root at least n
and
compare this to the single round and
sample based private coin interactive
roof system we saw earlier
there we have c times s for for constant
epsilon we have c times s
something like log m
so
public coin interactions are much more
restricted compared to the private coins
even focusing your hub
okay so let's see now a sketch of the
proof of our introduction remember that
we have a
query based interactive groove system
and we need to build the sample-based
interactive cool system
but we also need to make a couple of
assumptions on the interactive proof
system that we start with
and we need it to be a public coins
protocol
and now we can assume without loss of
generality that the verifier queries the
input only at the end of the interaction
because
all of its messages are random mixed
so it cannot
they cannot be depend on the queries it
makes during the interaction so just
assume it performs all of the queries
after the interaction ends
the second assumption we need to make
is that the locations of the queries
that the verifier makes at the end of
the protocol
depend
only on the public coins that it sends
to the public proven
in particular
they don't depend
on the messages it gets from the border
and
those assumptions might look a bit uh
too much
but for the
query-based interactive proof systems
that we that we have
well which we apply on the reduction
those protocols have those properties
so we are fine
and the high level idea of the reduction
is as follows
we need a sample based
proof system for the claim x in l
we have a query based in protocol for
this claim but we don't have query
access to x
so what we are going to do is to permute
the input x
according to some temptation
we are going to have x composition pi as
the permuted input
so x composition pi at index i
equals x
at location
power phi
and now we are going to execute the
query based interactive proof system we
have on the claim
x composition pi in l composition pi
so we're going to execute the protocol
on a different input and a different
language
so the seduction is actually not from a
language to a language it's for families
of languages we start with one language
and we end with another language
and indeed we apply this reduction for
families
of languages
and we need the families to be rich
enough so that if l is in the language
the
language l composition pi would also be
in the language
so this is the high level idea and now
let's discuss the actual protocol
sample based protocol that's the
verifier is going to execute
the
verifier starts by drawing samples from
the input x
let's say the indices of the samples
were s
and now is going to toss privately coins
and that it would have needed
to toss for execution of the query based
protocol for
the claim x pi in lp
and it can do it on its own privately
because it's just thousand coins and
record
what two of the results
next is going to use the assumptions
that the query locations it
needs to query
at the end of the query-based protocol
depend only on the public coins so it's
going to compute in the sq
which it would have needed to query
at the end of the query based protocol
for x by l time
if the public coins during this protocol
next
he's going to find a permutation that
sends q to s
and is going to send this permutation to
the program
and now the verifier together with the
proverb are going to execute the
interactive proof system we know we have
for the claim x pi in lp
but instead of using fresh randomness
to execute this protocol
the verifier is going to use
the public coins that we post privately
before
now at the end of the query based
protocol the verifier needs to
query the input of this claim they put x
type in some query locations
but what are going to be those locations
well
in the way we chose qm
q is exactly those locations the
locations that needs to be queried
from expire
in this protocol when raw are the public
coins used
but from the choice of pi
x composition pi at location q
equals to x at locations s
and exit location s we have those values
those are the values that we had from
the first step where the verifier
sampled the input x
so we can do it
so the verify can accept this protocol
and query the input x pi at the end of
the protocol
and we get also completeness
completeness and sounds for the protocol
because if x is in l
then x pi is in l pi
and in addition if x is epsilon form l
then x pi
is epsilon 5 from l pi
but there are still a couple of issues
with this protocol as i presented it now
since
the verifier needs to send
pi to the approval
but the representation length of an
arbitrary permutation can be long it
could be something like n log n
and this results with a protocol with a
communication complexity which is not
sublinal so this is a problem
and another issue
is that
pi
the the choice of pi depends on q and q
depends on wrong
so when we send pi to the program
we might reveal information regarding
growth public coins which are going to
be used in the protocol
and this is a big problem because the
soundness of the protocol of any
protocol really relies on the fact that
the proverb doesn't know
what
are the public coins that are going what
are the coins that are going to be used
during this protocol
so we might hurt the soundness of the
queerbase protocol by revealing
information
our solution to both of these issues
is to use a family of kos independent
permutations uh so a family of kos
independent permutations
is a family formulations where if we
sample a permutation from this family
it will form that random
and we look at the output of this
permutation
on sets of size at most k
then you cannot distinguish between this
permutation and a totally random
permutation that was chosen from the set
of all possible permutations
and we know constructions of such
such families where the representation
size
of the permutations is about decay and
here we use the chemicals the size of q
which is the query complexity
of the original protocol
and
we also proved in the paper
that
if we choose such a permutation it
doesn't reveal any information q
so this works because
we chose pi according to its values on a
set of size k
and we chose those values according to
the samples and the samples themselves
are totally random
so by sending pi to the prover
assuming that the indices s are random
we don't revealing any information on
queue
so we have a complete completeness and
soundness for the protocol but we need
the but we still need to show
that the sample and communication
complexities are as promised before
for the sample complexity and you can
see that
we draw centers that set one step at the
first step of the protocol and the
number of samples we draw is over the q
which is the query complexity of a query
based
protocol
for the communication complexity
well we execute the query based
interactive protocol so we need to pay
the communication complexity of this
protocol
and in addition we need to send pipe to
the cover and this requires as we said
before
about q bits
now what about the verify running time
here there is a an issue because
finding a pi
such that pi of k equals s
finding the pi in this family of k y's
independent permutations can take a lot
of time we don't really know of any
good way
to get such a permutation
which is better than just sampling
permutations from this family until we
hit by luck
a good permutation
that sends q2s
so the solution we use in the paper
is a instead of using random equals
independent permutations we use [ __ ]
independent hash functions
this
raises considerable complications
to the proof
and you can see the paper to see how we
deal
with them
so this concludes
[Music]
the sketch of the proof of our reduction
of our main result and
and i think that this reduction
really shows that in some sense
interactive protocols with sample based
access are really powerful
and you can deal with them like
almost pay everything you can do it in
some sense everything you can do with
queer-based protocols
well we showed it only for some families
we start with
private coin protocol and we end with
public coin protocol the communication
complexity might increase
but
it is very different than what we had
with testers with testers
query based access was much more
powerful than sample based taxes
and in addition
sample based interactive protocols are
so powerful that even with a single
round
for quality testing and for other
similar problems we can get a
lot of improvement over what we can do
with testers
we also saw that for
a quality testing the interaction and
private coins are really needed to get
the good sample and communication
complexities we had
i want to to finish with a couple of
fairly questions we have
so
the first one is about the power of
public coin
sample based
protocols
in reduction we ended up with a private
coin
sample-based
ibp
and is it really needed or can we
somehow improve this production
to be a public one
or in the other way
maybe we can find
a language that has
a public coin query based ipp where the
queries depend only on the public coins
but it doesn't have any sub-linear
public coin sample-based typically
the second question
is about
understanding better
the relationship between very query
based ipp and sample based id
and so save it with a language that has
a query based ipp
but it's private coins or maybe it's
public coins
but
the queries depend on the messages that
the approval says that's the only thing
given that protocol
can we extend the reduction to support
such languages
and lastly the focus of this work was on
interactive proof system interactive
sample-based proof systems
and we consider non-interactive proof
systems only for
quality testing and only for the lower
one
but we think that there are interesting
objects that one might study
and to understand what we can do with
them and what we cannot do
this is all i had
to say today
and thank you for listening